>>Brenda Marshall: Thank you so much for being
here. And thank you so much for inviting me.
This is a great opportunity to talk about
'Dakota Or What's a Heaven for?' And this
book is literary historical fiction set in
late 19th century Dakota Territory.
And several of the readers have observed,
incorrectly, that it is modeled on 19th century
fiction. Those sort of large, sprawling Victorian
fictions that have a wide tapestry in the
background made up of different strata of
society.
So here we have politicians and industrialists,
railroad executives, bonanza farmers, homesteaders.
And that tapestry that is woven through the
background that has individual stories that
we become interested in. And then there are
threads from each of those stories that work
their way into the center, the central narrative
rather, of the novel.
And that is a story about a woman who marries
a man, Percy, in order to stay close to Percy's
sister, Anna. And in the late 19th century,
in this part of the world, at this time, it's
the most she can imagine in terms of staying
close to this other woman.
So I'm going to read a couple of different
sections. And iIn the midst of reading, while
I'm reading, talk a little bit about what
is going on for some of the characters and
what is going on for me as a, as an author
thinking about these characters. And then
I hope to be able to talk about the book with
y'all. Any questions that come up. And so.
"You will say that I'm just making this up
as if it were a small matter to invent truth.
Accuse me rather of excess. For what can invention
add to fact in the land where trains leave
their rails to sail through the air, men are
born of frozen beasts and locusts feast on
human flesh."
So that's the first couple sentences of the
book and with those first sentences is introduced
one of the central themes of the book and
that has to do with narrative in the sense
of who tells what stories to whom and what
stories do we tell ourselves to ourselves
in order to proclaim and endorse a particular
identity that we feel.
And do those stories have to be true in order
to be powerful? And so there's lots of different
ways that narrative works throughout this
book. And as I read a little bit more from
the preamble, you will be able to sense how
stories are beginning to function in this
novel.
Now the preamble itself is a 19th century
convention for novels. And it sort of works
as a port, an entry way that brings readers
into the book. And so it introduces you to
some characters and some themes that are at
work.
So about the flesh- eating locusts.
[man laughs]
[audience titters]
I have proof.
Here is General Alfred Sully's report to the
Secretary of War in August of 1864 regarding
the carnivorous bugs.
"A soldier on his way here lay down to sleep
on the prairie in the middle of the day. The
troop had been marching all night. His comrades
noticed him covered with grasshoppers and
awakened him. His throat and wrists were bleeding
from the bites of the insects." But perhaps,
General Sully, seeking to fill the unearthly
void of this strange land with words, had
been provoked into exaggeration. For it was
he who referred to my home as 'Hell with the
fires out'.
So I invent. I embellish. I exaggerate. It
is my heritage. In fact, it was a singularly
brilliant advertising campaign by a railroad
on the verge of bankruptcy that transformed
Sully's hell into the Nile of the North. Listen
and tell me if you can name this place.
It is a land fair enough to tempt the angels
in their flight to wonder whether a new and
better Eden has not been formed and roofed
with sapphire skies. That's right. Dakota
Territory. The angels, as is generally the
case, resisted the temptation to tarry. But
Norwegians, Swedes, Danes, Finns, Icelanders,
Germans, and Russians came in droves.
There were Moravians and Mennonites and Methodists
and Lutherans and the occasional Jew and even
some Catholics. Slum dwellers pried themselves
loose from the muck and stink of Eastern cities.
Jews left villages in Russia to sink cement
mikvaehs into the prairie.
Newly freed black men set up tonsorial palaces
in prairie towns and learned to speak Norwegian
to their customers. Farmers, some of them
real Americans, pulled up stakes in Michigan
and Nebraska and Iowa to try their luck behind
a plow in the new Northwest.
'Wrong side up,' the Indians said, shaking
their heads at the white men intent upon turning
under perfectly good prairie grass.
I could begin this story of an unlikely place
composed in equal parts of excess and lack.
Those opposites so fully integrated into the
regional psyche as to be indistinguishable
anywhere. And too much would be left out.
I sort of liked the part about how glaciers
once covered the Northern Plains. But a glacial
paced reader would surely tax your patience.
As for the millennia when Native Americans
and their ancestors spent a few months of
each year hunting here, that is not my story
to tell.
I will skip to the pre-territory trading and
trapping days and the stories of forts and
soldiers, of treaties made and broken, and
of smallpox and Indian agents and graft and
despair and fury and get right to the real
excitement. Farming."
[audience chuckles]
So as the, as the preamble progresses, it
gives a little bit of history and very quickly,
I'll run through that.
The Northern tier of the Dakotas was essentially
colonized by the Northern Pacific Railroad
that had a land grant to build a railroad
from Duluth to Puget Sound. And it went bankrupt
very quickly in Bismarck. Had no money but
it had lots of people with lots of stocks
and bonds.
So what – an executive from the railroad
came up with this idea.
[crowd noise in background]
"Look we've got these vast plains that we
need to populate if we are going to have any
market. And what we need is we need to get
somebody farming this land. So let's go to
all those people, generally wealthy industrialists
from the East, who have stocks that are increasingly
worthless. Let them trade those for all this
land under the condition that they put the
land into production.
So what you ended up with would be some of
the directors from the railroad, wealthy industrialists
from the East who would have like huge, huge
parcels of land in the Dakotas. For maybe
as much as 25 cents per acre, they would end
up with 40 square miles of farming. Bring
in sort of a migrant force to farm the land
and then stay away. So they weren't really
part of the community but they had all this
land.
Now interspersed amongst these what was known
as 'Railroad Land' would have been the government
land that was being sold, being parceled off
to – apportioned off, rather, to homesteaders.
So all of a sudden, there's this huge conflict,
class conflict that gets set up right away.
People who are absent with a lot of money
and a lot of land. People who are living on
the land and trying to make it without much
money. One hundred sixty acres would have
been just one quarter of a square mile.
So this gets back to that sense of narrative
because the Dakotas are not necessarily an
easy place to live. And bBut Dakotans love
to tell themselves the story about 'how hardy
we are. Nobody else could live here. We're
the only ones who couldan live here.'
And so there's this story sort of helps people
to live in that particular place. So I'm going
to pick up on the top of page four for those
of you who have a book there.
"The advertisements about the Dakotas had
told the truth about the fertile land of the
Red River Valley of the Dakota Territory.
About the miracles of sunsets that set the
prairies ablaze with color. The blue skies
that clap the land with clarity. The peace
of space.
But they hadn't mentioned the wind or the
dust or the hale or the tornadoes or the locusts.
'A sea of grass' did not translate in the
immigration leaflets into 'no trees'. And
few could imagine the cramped isolation of
a 10 by 12 foot shanty on the Dakota prairie.
Inside, no privacy. Outside, no neighbors.
The settlers discovered soon enough that there
was no market for their wheat nearby and,
unlike the bonanza farmers, they did not get
special transport rates from the railroad
or special storage rates for the elevators
that were owned by the railroad. They did
not receive rebates from the milling companiesy.
They paid retail prices for their machinery.
Their interest rates from the banks in the
East were high. Twenty percent was not uncommon.
So they told themselves the story. They were
special because they could live in this place
of wind and dust and haille and tornadoes
and locusts despite the railroad, the milling
companies, the implement dealers and the bankers.
The story gave them back their independence.
That narrative of independence remains as
powerful, as false, as necessary as ever in
the Dakotas.
[crowd noise increases in the background]
It has become our fetish replacing the lost
object of desire, the impossible place that
never was. You have been told that there is
nothing there. I tell you there is too much.
Even when there is nothing, there is too much
of it.
And who am I? I'm an old politician pretty
close to honest and I know the stories of
this territory from before there was such
a thing.
I am the Land Commissioner for the Northern
Pacific Railroad in charge of the Land and
Immigration Department. Sometimes in my dreams
I wear a robe and flowing beard. And behind
me the multitudes flow towards this land of
milk and honey.
I am a Scot from Ontario and I have come to
this land to chew it up and make myself fat.
Someday I will be called 'The Boss of North
Dakota'.
I am just a girl from Norway. I am Frances
Louise Houghton Bingham, daughter-in-law of
John Bingham, wife of his son, Percy, friend
of Percy's sister, Anna. And I mean for this
to be my story. It too is a story of what
a woman's patience can endure as well as what
a woman's resolution can achieve. As to whether
that refers in this case to one woman or two,
you will have to make up your own mind.
And so, reader, to Frances, alone in the bedroom
she shares with her husband in his father's
home in St. Paul, Minnesota. It is January
of 1874. There is a photograph in her hand."
So with that, you get the sort of the porch,
I said. The introduction into the central
story. And much of the story is going to follow
this character, Frances Houghton Bingham,
who is not necessarily nice. She does things
she ought not to do.
But I really hope as readers read her, that
they sort of end up liking her and thinking,
'Yes. You tried that.'
Now one of the things that happens is that
John Bingham, her father-in-law, becomes a
bonanza farmer, moves to Dakota Territory.
Her husband, who wants to be a journalist,
moves to Fargo and leaving the two women,
the sister and sister-in-law, Frances, my
character, and the object of her affection,
Anna, behind.
And pretty soon, they decide that it's time
to bring the women out West to see the bonanza
farm. And the part I'm going to read from
now is the very first time that Anna and Frances
– I'm on page 131. It's in the chapter in
which the women go West. And this is as they
are going to the Dakotas for the very first
time on their own.
[pause]
"Fatigued by her mother's final illness, death,
and funeral, by the business of closing up
the Summit House, and packing for a two week
visit to Fargo, by the almost twenty hour
trip, Anna had finally given in to the locomotion's
lulling rock. The colorful bird that completes
the red and black silk trim of her small chip
hat cushions her head against the window as
if there its flight has tragically ended.
As Frances watches, Anna's lips part. But
immediately with the rigor of manners that
the barely asleep will maintain, she brings
them together again. Frances waits, pleasantly
aware of the pulse beating in her own throat,
of the heat that flushes her skin. And then,
as she had hoped, Anna's lips part again,
just enough to show the tips of her teeth.
A tiny thread of saliva appears as Anna's
jaw relaxes. Anna's tongue darts between her
lips before they close. Again, even now, as
Anna sleeps, rocked into somnolence by the
train's rhythm, she maintains the air of serenity
that she has cultivated in response to her
body's aches.
The effort this composure has painted, has
painted a patina of maturity upon Anna's face
that heightens her beauty beyond the promise
of her early conventional prettiness. She
is a beautiful woman, suffering beautifully.
And Frances loves her for it.
Odd, Frances thinks, relaxing into a more
leisurely study of Anna's figure, how the
absence of the other Binghams, consistently
of John, frequently of Percy, and now permanently
of Anna's mother, Rhoda, has made it less
easy for her to openly observe her beloved.
Whereas triangulated conversation allows for
the casual study of another, a tête à tête
calls for strict policing of the gaze, directed
toward the eyes, always, forbidden to drop
to the full lips, the swell of the breasts,
the curve of the hip, the ankle.
So here, on the final stretch of the long
train ride on a warm August day, Frances takes
advantage of the opportunity to look, just
look, and dream.
Rhoda Bingham's death has cemented the women's
relationship in a way that Frances could not
have anticipated."
So I am going to skip a few paragraphs because
[audience member coughs]
then Frances begins to think of something
in the past and I am going to keep on going
with the present here.
"And still Frances thinks her focus for the
moment on Anna's hands primly folded on her
lap. She is not satisfied. She wants more
than the love and affection that Anna so willingly
offers her friend and sister-in-law. She desires
the unknown and that is hard to come by.
'This', Frances thinks, silently addressing
her sleeping companion, 'is where we differ.
You, Anna, are satisfied to be and I am desperate
to become. But become what?' Frances chuckles
to herself thinking, 'I am become Percy. That's
what. With my head in the clouds and my mind
filled with if, if, if. Well then, if what?'
Despite the very visceral pleasure Frances
takes in her appraisal of Anna, she is not
such an aberration of her sex that she believes
in her power to aeffect great change. She
is not a wealthy capitalist, a Frederick Billings
whose plan for reorganization, she has heard,
has saved a railroad intact.
She is not a professional man, a J. B. Power,
say, whose vision has set in motion an advertising
campaign of such sweep and breadth that it
promises to dot the wilderness of wildflowers
and grass with farm and hamlets.
She is not even an Alexander MacKenzie, described
to her by Percy as uneducated and illiterate
but unabashed ambition for he believes that
a man can begin with nothing and build a kingdom
out of nowhere. Percy says he has chosen Bismarck.
No. Frances cannot build. She cannot bank.
She cannot broadcast, buy, or bully. Those
are things for a man to do. A woman's desires
must be subtle if she knows and it will cause
her naught but pain should her reach exceed
her grasp.
Still, if she has been taught to want less,
it does not follow that she will want less
desperately. And so Frances waits."
So what happens, soon thereafter, is that
Frances herself is somewhat seduced but unexpectedly
by, not so much by another person but by this
place, this place that is Dakota. There is
all sorts of boosters at this time talking
about how glorious this place was.
And most of the language was fairly empty.
It was just meant to get people into the Dakotas.
And then over and over again, in the, in the
diaries that I would read [clears throat].
Excuse me. Or the histories or reading letter
press books and archives, I would get this,
hear this tone from people who were essentially
being seduced by their own language. And sort
of falling in love with the place and with
the potential of the place. [takes sip of
water]
[pause]
So now Anna and Frances are dragging out to
see the land that is under cultivation. I'm
going to page ,– let's see, – 143. And
as they are driving towards this land that
is under cultivation, towards the bonanza
farm which isn't really a farm yet at this
point; – it's just people farming. There
isn't actually a homestead, yet.
They see something.
[pause]
You have to imagine. There's something -- they're
driving in one direction in their buggy and
something appears from the left.
"Anna and John Bingham too look toward the
approaching spectacle that had burst forth
from a stand of scrub trees that stood at
the edge of the sloughue they had been skirting
for the past half mile as they neared the
Cheyenne River. Seeing that the apparition
was itself on a dirt path precisely perpendicular
to their own, John Bingham pulled the bay
to a stop.
Silently the Binghams watched the cloud of
dust clarify into a team of four workhorses
pulling an empty farm wagon at a dead run,
piloted, piloted by what proved to be a young
woman who drove the horses forward while standing
on the wagon seat, reins held tightly in her
left hand, whip cracking regularly from her
right.
Without so much as a glance at the tidy buggy
with its fancy bay crow stepping in agitation,
the wagon's driver hurtled the team forward
and past. Within moments, the spectacle had
diminished into a receding line of dust.
When John Bingham allowed the bay to step
forward, Anna was released of speech but she
did not get beyond the obvious.
'That was a woman.' Anna's incredulity was
clearly mixed with horror. 'She wore no hat.'
Anna summed the impossibility of what she
had seen.
'Shame to see a team driven like that for
no good reason,' Bingham said. 'Most of the
settlers around here, immigrant or not, don't
really have the leisure for a fine distinction
between masculine and feminine duties.'"
Now as they are speaking, Frances is thinking
again. She's watching again, what she has
just seen.
"As John Bingham spoke, Frances let herself
see again the young woman and her team as
it flew past. The brownness of the girl's
face was unfortunate, to be sure, and the
thin ropes of muscle that stood out upon her
forearm as she grasped the handful of thick
reins had been unsightly.
But the hair that had come loose and flowed
wildly behind her, the calico dress opened
at the throat, the sun and breeze, the skirt
pressing against her long legs that bent and
moved with the bouncing of the wagon upon
the rough track like agile springs. Why, it
had been a breathtaking display, as much for
its grace and force as in its inappropriateness.
Frances shifted in her seat to rearrange the
coils of her bustle and relieve the press
of her corset into her side that, a moment
ago, she had not noticed. The pads, so recently
pinned into the sleeves of her dress, were
already moist. Again, she imagined the girl
who had flown past.
'What,' she wondered, 'must that feel like?'
And what was this place from which such impossibilities
could spring? Perhaps Anna's analogy of the
empty frame, the unpainted canvas, was apt.
Perhaps here was a place in which Frances
could paint herself into a sensible world.
Perhaps here in this world of the known and
the necessary, of men involved in industry
and agriculture and railroads and politics,
of settlers and storekeepers, Yankees and
immigrants, capitalists and laborers, there
would be space for a new life, heretofore
unknown.
She could happily dot her canvas with these
horses, oxen, machinery, and men that she
could now see moving among the expanse of
gold they approached for they all struck her
as strangely beautiful in their purpose and
energy.
She was about to ask her father-in-law to
stop the buggy so she could better study this
bustling tableau, a rectangle of labor surrounded
by an expanse of untrammeled prairie, when
he did just that.
Individually each team of harvesters followed
the trajectory of a straight line. In unison,
they formed a wedge of progress.
'Yes, there', Frances thought. Not in the
center but well in the background. Perhaps
in the vanishing point on the horizon toward
which the wedge's line directed her eye. There
she could paint her life with Anna."
So there's a sense that Frances begins to
think [audience member sneezes], 'Okay. There's
this empty space. Here's this empty canvas.
I'm going to imagine the unimaginable. I'm
going to try to make possible' what she conceived
to be as impossible.
And I don't, I will give you no spoilers but
I will say that, that again much of the narrative
of what was possible was deeply gendered and
some things were not going to be available
for women that were available for men.
But also it was sort of a certain sign of
her own upper class background that she was
able to even imagine making the space for
herself.
But I don't want to suggest that there were
not possibilities for women because absolutely
there were. For example, women could take
homesteads. Women could have a place of their
own.
Now I want to read one more short passage.
And before I read that passage, I just need
to give you a little bit of background.
So one of the other themes that's at work
in the novel has to do with transformation.
We, of course, have the transformation of
this prairie into a place of agriculture.
But there are also several characters who
represent this transformation.
So, for example, there's a man who leaves
Russia as Yitzhak Shavinitz and he leaves
New York as Isaac Shavinitz and he steps off
the train in Fargo Dakota Territory as Jack
Shaw.
[audience chuckles]
And so part of what happens is that we look
at what are the gains and what are the losses.
When you shear off a part of your identity
to take on a new identity, what happens?
There's a character named Little Carl who
is the farm cook who goes through a more dramatic
transformation. I can't say any more about
him because that certainly would be a spoiler.
And then there was another character, Kirsten
Knudson. Now Kirsten was meant to be a peripheral
character who sort of represented that transformation
from young immigrant girl to American woman.
And Kirsten just grew and grew and grew as
I wrote. Now partly it was because I gave
drinking caffeine about 10 years ago.
[audience laughs]
But I discovered with Kirsten, I needed to
drink caffeine to do her voice. And so maybe
I was just allowing myself more caffeine than
I was used to.
[audience laughs]
Or maybe there's something about that caffeine
that made me write more. I don't know. But
her voice just grew and it became more and
more important to the center of the book.
And the book is written in third person but
Kirsten's voice was always in first person.
I always heard her speaking, 'I' this, 'I'
that. And I thought, 'Well, I'll just go with
the voice that I'm comfortable with and then,
when it comes time to finish the book, I'll
transfer her into third person. How hard can
that be?'
Impossible. She was just, she was just the
person in this book who was going to be 'I',
first person, and not – and it took me,
it took me years to figure out why that made
sense. I think that authors don't always know
why they are doing what they are doing. [clears
throat] But it makes sense that Kirsten speaks
in the first person.
And so this is just a little bit from Kirsten's
voice. I'm on page 157 from the chapter in
which Kirsten begins to learn about love.
And one of the things also about Kirsten is,
one of the joys writing her is that this book
takes place over an eight or nine period of
years, of time. And if she's a young immigrant
girl becoming American, her language has to
constantly change. And so this was one of
the challenges of writing the book, was to
make her sound like she had taken on more
language with each. with each year and she
loves language. So Kirsten Knudson.
"Kirsten Knudson, Kirsten Knudson, Kirsten
Knudson. That is my name still. I hope it
always is to be."
'Mor' which is Norwegian for 'mother'.
"Mor says it is different that I will feel
someday and all I can say is that I will have
to feel very different than I feel now if
I'm to feel different about that some day.
And if I do feel different and that is as
Mrs. Harkness, my teacher, said last October
when I asked if the Sullivan boys would be
coming back to school to be neither encouraged
or anticipated.
I do not think I will feel like being Kirsten
Rolstrud. That is the name that is on the
paper that I am putting into the firebox of
the stove. When Mor comes through the door
with a load of kindling that my sisters, Haldis
and Gree and I are all the time to pick up
in the trees by the river. Now why do I have
such a piece of paper?
Did I write it myself? Ja.
Well then you would not ask such a thing to
look at the writing you did. Mrs. Harkness
says that for writing I have the finest something,
something -- it is a long word – of all
her students. Her students know more that
is although some will be but not me because
this year, Mrs. Harkness is to teach at her
home in Fargo. And that is too far for me
to go evveery day.
And of the school I've had enough, father
says, because I'm a girl and almost 15 years
old. Ole, he says that it is it is not a real
school anyway. And that there is a real school
in Fargo now with a real teacher, a Mrs. Giddings.
And that Mrs. Harkness is – oh never mind
what Ole says. It is not always so nice and
that is not the point.
The point is that the name 'Kirsten Rolstrud'
on the paper is like one of Mor's hens got
a pencil in its beak and then tried to stab
a bug with it and kept missing. And I am saying
right here and right now that every single
one of Mor's hens is with more sense than
Halber Rolstrud who is the one to write that
name and then hand it to me when I am walking
out of the door after hearing Pere Rolstrud's
Sunday morning sermon.
And that is, as Mrs. Harkness would say, taking
the undue advantage. And that means I think
to do something that the done to would like
to undo."
[audience chuckles]
So that's Kirsten and she's a lot of fun to
work with and again, she ends up being one
of the just and fairly large figure in the
book when she was just supposed to be this
girl off to the side.
[man chuckles]
So that's the reading and I would love to
answer any questions that you guys have or
to talk about this book.
Anything?
>>Male Audience Member #1: Yeah. Where did
sort of , -- clearly landscape and geography
is really rooted here. Is that where the story
started for you? Was it with the land or was
it with the characters?
>>Brenda Marshall: That's a great question.
I think that if you are a Dakotan and you
are writing, it's a given that you have to
write about land.
>>Male Audience Member #1: Uh huh.
>>Brenda Marshall: That it is so much a part
of our psyche and they know there are lots
of sociologists, psychologists who sort of
argue against this notion of a regional psyche.
But I think absolutely there are different
regional identities.
>>Male Audience Member #1: Yeah.
>>Brenda Marshall: We are formed by a space
as much as by people. And there is something
about that space and again, most of this book
is set in the Eastern part of the Dakotas
which is very flat. It's as flat as this table
top. And then the further west you get, you
get into the rolling hills. And then you get
into the Badlands.
But sSo there is within those of us who are
from that place, there is a sense of needing
to be, have an openness around us. And for
example, often you will notice how people
have different air, spaces around them when
they talk. And a Dakotan will always have
about an arm's length
.And if somebody moves into that emotional
space, he'll just keep moving, just keep moving
back into the corner. So there's this emotional
space that reflects the physical space. But
there are all, the characters were also pretty
crucial to me as I began. And the story has
this long evolution and the evolution of some
of the characters started before I realized
I was working on this novel.
So right after I finished my first novel,
'Mavis', my partner and I were on vacation
on Pawley Island and we were like good tourists.
We were in one of these tourists shops flipping
through postcards and all these vintage postcards
that have a funny line at the bottom.
And there was one postcard and there were
15 young women on it. And one of the women
just caught my attention. She just didn't
look like any of the rest of them. She just
looked so smart. It was just one of those
where the eyes come out of the photograph.
So I sat down that week and wrote a short
story. I don't write short stories but it
seemed like a good thing to do. And it is
published in the most obscure journal in the
world. I mean you would have to look very
hard to find this journal in England and I
don't recommend that you do.
Anyway, so then I put that story aside and
I thought, 'Well, I am going to write a story
about Dakota territory' 'cause I thought the
history's interesting. And I started working
on that. This is 10 years ago or over 10 years
ago.
Then another story intervened, one that became
emotionally more important to me. So I put
the notion of writing a story about Dakota
territory away and worked on this other book.
It wasn't until 2001 that I thought, 'Okay
I'm ready to go back to a story about Dakota
territory, homesteading, bonanza farming,
all that.' But there was that character from
almost forgotten short story waiting for me
in a sense. And so I brought her back into
the story. And it had nothing to do with that
short story I had written. It was just that
character who was ready to be developed.
And so in that sense, it began with that character.
And then it also began also with this other
character, Anna. And I had, I had the ending.
I rarely have the ending to a book in mind
when I write but I had this perfect ending.
I even had the line. I could hardly wait to
get there
[audience laughs]
because I had the line.. And then Anna refused
to do what I wanted her to do. It just historically
was not honest. She just could not act the
way I wanted her to act. She was not going
to give either me or Frances what we wanted.
And I just think that this is part of writing
honest historical fiction. You realize at
some point that you may have an idea where
you think your story's going to go and then
you just realize to be honest, your character's
not going to do that. Your character's not
going to think that. Your character's not
going to go there.
And so I ended up rethinking the novel and
fortunately other characters stepped up to
the plate and helped me come to a resolution.
So there's this kind of a combination of land
and characters working at the same time.
>>Female Audience Member #1: It seems like
when you're doing historical fiction, you
have to do a lot of research to make sure
that you're not just fantasizing.
>>Brenda Marshall: Making stuff up.
[audience laughs]
>>Female Audience Member #1: Like you said,
you had the perfect ending but you knew your
character wouldn't do that. So how did you
go about the research process?
>>Brenda Marshall: Lots of fun ways and lots
of sort of rigorous ways. The fun way is that
for a couple of years while I was writing,
two straight years, I didn't allow myself
to read any fiction for fun outside the 19th
century. And that was basically to allow a
certain cadence to come into my writing so
I could hear voices. And then just a lot of
archival research so the Institute for Research..
[pause].
Is that right? Nope. The Institute for Regional
Studies that published this book at North
Dakota State University has terrific archives
and I spent a couple of summers in those archives
reading letter press books of executives.
They would write their letters and they'd
be on sort of a carbon copy and they'd be
in big books. So I could read year after year
of their books.
And that allowed me to understand what was
happening with the railroad, what was happening
with politics, what was happening with the
homesteaders, the bonanza farmers. And then
just going, spending a lot of time reading
history books, reading memoirs, diaries. But
the fun about being a novelist. I was going
to say, 'The fun of being a novelist as opposed
to being a professor; but of course being
a professor is a lot of fun too.
But the fun of being a novelist as opposed
to a rigorous historian is that you get to
allow for a lot of space of serendipity. So
if I am, was looking on microfilm at a particular
Dakota Territory newspaper for something that
might have been happening in the legislature
at that particular time, and over on this
side I see a, something like a classified
that says, 'Mrs. So-and-So has left my bed
and board and I am refusing to pay her bills.
Mr. So-and-So.'
And all of a sudden, you think, 'Who puts
this in a newspaper in the first place?'
[audience laughs]
And secondly what's the story behind this?
So all of a sudden, I may be paying attention
to what's going on over here but I'm copying
this down and thinking, 'Is there a place
where this will work in my novel?' And often
answers to plot problems, I found seren-,
serendip-, serendipitously through just flipping
through journals or newspapers or things like
that. And as a scholar, I enjoyed that sort
of research and so it all came, -- everything
kind of fit together. Good question.
>>Female Audience Member #2: How do you go
about getting your book published? Like did
you say that the North Dakota,..
>>Brenda Marshall: The North Dakota State
University Institute for Regional Studies.
[audience laughs]
Thank you. I got it.
>>Female Audience Member #2: So did they give
you a grant to start this or did you finish
the book and go to them? Or how,..
>>Brenda Marshall: It actually backs up a
little bit because my first novel had been
published by a mainstream New York press.
My hope of course was to go back to them because
that's where most of the marketing will be
available. And, but my agent went, my agent
was the -- first you have to have an agent.
You have to have a literary agent
>>Female Audience Member #2: Right.
>>Brenda Marshall: in New York. And for this
type of book, but my agent wasn't able to
sell it to one of the New York houses. And
I kept getting this thing over and over again,
which was: 'Love the story. Great writing.
Great characters. We've never read this story
before but we don't know how we would market
it to a wide audience.'
Because they, they have jobs to keep and they
have, -- it all has a lot to do with selling
books which in some ways that's too bad because
there are a lot of really great books that
aren't making it into that best seller range.
Anyway so then I said to my agent, 'Let's
try University Presses because there is a,
it is [pause] honest historical fiction and
it is literary historical fiction. So I think
the University Presses would work.'
I actually went to undergraduate school in
North Dakota State University. So my agent
was able to talk to the people back there
and I was able to talk to them and they were
thrilled. They have actually been thrilled
to publish this book and have done just a
gorgeous job with it. And there's actually
something kind of positive about not having
a mainstream New York house which I would
have not have complained about.
Don't get me wrong. But with, -- if a book
is published, say by Random House or Knopf
for something big and splashy, it doesn't
have much time to make it on the bookshelf.
And we all know the bookshelves are sort of
disappearing. And so you, -- the, -- there's
a sense that you make it right away or you
don't. But the joy of having a University
Press to do this is that they're in it for
the long haul. And so there can be this sort
of grass roots understanding that there is
a good book out there and word of mouth still
does sell books and still does get enthusiasm
going.
But also I'm lucky in that I have an e-publisher
and so people who do not have access to -- it's
available on Amazon dot com too. But who don't
want to buy a hardback can get it on any e-reader
which is a useful thing these days when book
stores are sort of disappearing.
[pause]
Anything else?
>>Female Audience Member #3: So who do you
feel like were your biggest mentors or are
your mentors in the industry?
>>Brenda Marshall: I don't know that I actually
have mentors in the industry. I have people
who have been very, very good to me and helpful.
I am one of these writers who does not really
like to share work while I'm writing. I want
to be as done as I can get before I actually
show somebody. And then a process of revision
always happens. The agent says, 'Well'.
My agent, when she first read my book which
is 200 pages longer, she said, 'You have two
wonderful books here. You have a history book
and a novel. [audience laughs] Which one would
you like to publish?'
So then it comes back to me and I have to
get rid of 200 pages which was probably a
good thing to do. Broke my heart but I did
it. And again it was a good thing to do. So
then there's that sort of revising going on
and editors will ask for revisings.
But for the most part, I want to -- it's not
so much that I only trust myself. It's that
I don't trust that I won't take advice that
isn't good. I really trust readers when they
talk to me and they say, 'Well this didn't
work. This didn't work. This could have been
better.'
And I think, 'Okay. I have to change this.
I have to change that. I have to make this
better.''
And then a part of me thinks, 'Is that true
to the book itself, to the heart of the book
itself?'
And so that's why I work mostly on my own.
But there are people saying, people at the
University of Michigan. Peter Ho Davies has
been, was good enough to write this lovely
blurb on the background, on the back, comparing
my book to George Eliot's 'Middlemarch'. Not.
[audience laughter]
I just want to say that that is, that is the
most wonderful thing that anybody could say.
I know who George Eliot is. I know. I know
how far to take that comparison. But what
he's talking, what he is saying is that there's
this big panoramic background and , or also
comparing it to Sarah Waters' fiction which
if you are readers of Sarah Waters, she writes
really terrific historical fiction.
Charlie Baxter used to teach here at the University
of Michigan. He's now at the University of
Minnesota. And his book, 'Feast of Love',
was a National Book Award finalist. And he
has been a good help to me throughout too.
In terms of actually -- those are the people
who help you once you've written the book
and are saying, 'Okay. I want to help this
see a public.' In terms of writers that have
been meaningful to me, I think I am more inclined
to talk about books that have been meaningful
as opposed to writers 'cause I often don't
follow one writer's work down the line.
I'll think after awhile and Salman Rushdie
is a terrific author whose first four books
I just could not read fast enough. And I don't
know if I'll read any more of his books. You
know you get to a point where you don't know
if you'll read any more.
'The Great Gatsby'. Jay Gatsby who was originally
James Gadson, -- I don't know if any of you
remember that, -- from North Dakota. That's
part of his, that's part of his story and
part of that drive. That belief that you can
do anything if just you work hard enough even
if what you want might not be such a good
thing. Or your drive.
The way you get what you want might not be
so good but that sense of 'ok, iIf I just
follow the rules, if I just fill in these
squares, I can succeed.' And that's a very
Midwestern, very North Dakota way of thinking.
So that book has been crucial to me.
'Middlemarch' again has been crucial just
in terms of watching
[pause]
George Eliot's intelligence work at work in
a novel. Just that, the bravery of watching
that much intelligence in the midst of a really
compelling story and of being able to devise
a world that was so huge, all at once. That
was, that was, that was pretty meaningful
to me. She's somebody's books I read over
and over and over again.
If anybody here has never read anything by
Marilyn Robinson, 'Housekeeping' is my favorite.
But she has others. That's a book, those are
books to run out and get. And again, she has
been an influence I would say in the sense
again of what quiet intelligence can do and
how much you can just fall in love with certain
characters. It is just her –' Housekeeping
' is just a small book but it is, it is, it
is so beautifully written.
I mean, I'm dobeing this advertisement for
'Housekeeping'.
[audience laughter[
It is so beautifully written that it almost
scans like poetry and yet it is smart and
it is funny and it is just, -- it is just
the book I think everybody ought to be reading.
[pause]
Anything else?
All right. Thank you.
Male Audience Member #2: Thank you so much.
This has been great.
[applause]